I believe there is beauty in hearing the
voices of people who haven't been heard
that's a complex idea because the things
that must be said are not always lovely
but somehow if they're reflective of
truth I think fundamentally that makes
them beautiful
[Music]
there's the aesthetic beauty of the work
that in some cases functions is more of
a Trojan horse it allows one to open
their hearts to difficult conversations
maybe you feel attracted to the beauty
and while compelled by the technique the
color the form of composition may be the
difficult conversation sneaks up
I really taught myself how to pay by
spending time at museums and looking at
the people that the artists rather that
I was told were the masters looking at
the Rembrandt's Renoir men a it becomes
quite obvious that if I'm going to learn
how to paint a self-portrait by studying
those people I'm gonna be challenged
when it comes to mixing my skin or
mixing the skin of those people and my
family there's literally formulas
written down historically to tell me how
to paint white skin what colors I should
use for the under painting what colors I
should use for the impasto highlights
that doesn't really exist for dark skin
it's not a thing it's not a thing
because the reality is our skin wasn't
considered beautiful
the picture of the world that is is
represented in the history of paintings
doesn't reflect me it doesn't reflect
the things that I value in that way and
that's the conflict that I struggle with
so frequently is I love the technique of
these paintings I have learned from the
technique of these paintings and yet I
know that they have no concern for me
and so there are so many of us who are
amending this history in order to simply
say we were there because you couldn't
see doesn't mean we weren't there
we have been there we have been here
we've continued to be seen as not
beautiful but we are and we are here so
many of the things that I make end up
it's may be futile attempts to reinforce
that idea
even though I've had the Western
training my eye is still drawn to the
folks who look like me and so sometimes
in my work I have used strategies like
widening out the rest of the composition
in order to focus on the character who
may go unseen otherwise I have cut out
other figures from the painting one to
either emphasize their absence or two to
get you to focus on the other folks in
the composition
so the Jerome project aesthetically
draws on hundreds of years of religious
icon painting a kind of aesthetic
structure that was reserved for the
church reserved for Saints
it's a project that is an exploration of
the criminal justice system not asking
the question are these people innocent
or guilty but more is this the way that
we should deal with our citizens
I started our body of work because after
being separated from my father for
almost 15 years I reconnected with my
father and I really didn't know how to
make a place for him in my life as with
most things I don't understand
I worked them out in the studio and so I
just started making these portraits of
mug shots starting because I did a
google search for my father just
wondering what had happened over this 15
year period where had he gone and I
found his mugshot which of course was of
no surprise but I found in that first
search 97 other black men is exactly the
same person last name and I found their
mug shots and that that was a surprise
and and not knowing what to do I just
started painting them initially the tar
was a formula that allowed me to figure
out how much of these men's life had
been lost to incarceration but I gave up
that and the tar became far more
symbolic as I continued because what I
realized is the amount of time that you
spend incarcerated is just the beginning
of how long is gonna impact the rest of
your life so in terms of beauty within
that context I know from my friends
family who have been incarcerated who
are currently incarcerated folks want to
be remembered folks want to be be seen
we put people away for a long time in
some cases for that one worse thing that
they've done and so to a degree it's a
way of just saying I see you we see you
and I think that as a gesture is
beautiful
in the painting behind the mists of
benevolence there is almost this curtain
of Thomas Jefferson painted and pulled
back to reveal a black woman who's
hidden this black woman is at once
Sallie Mae Hemings but she's also every
other black woman who was on that
plantation Monticello and all the rest
of them the one thing we do know about
Thomas Jefferson is that he believed in
Liberty
maybe more strongly than anyone who's
ever written about it and if we know
that to be true if we believe that to be
true
then the only benevolent thing to do in
that context would be to extend that
Liberty and so in this body of work I
use two separate paintings that are
forced together on top of one another to
emphasize this tumultuous relationship
between black and white in these
compositions and so that that
contradiction that devastating reality
that's always behind the curtain what is
happening in race relations in this
country that's what this painting is
about
the painting is called another fight for
remembrance the title speaks to
repetition the title speaks to the kind
of violence against black people by the
police has happened and continues to
happen and we are now saying it happened
again the painting is sort of
editorialized as a painting about
Ferguson it's not not about Ferguson but
it's also not not about Detroit it's
also not not about Minneapolis the
painting was started because on a trip
to New York to see some of my own art
with my brother as we spent hours
walking in and out of galleries we ended
the day by being stopped by an
undercover police car in the middle of
the street these two police officers
with their hands on their gun told us to
stop they put us up against the wall
they accused me of stealing art out of a
gallery space where I was actually
exhibiting art and as they stood there
with their hands on their weapons I
asked the police officer what was
different about my citizenship then that
of all the other people who were not
being disturbed in that moment he
informed me that they had been following
us for two hours and that they had been
getting complaints about black men two
black men walking in and out of
galleries
that painting is about the reality but
it's not a question of if this is gonna
happen again it's a question when this
most recent body of work is called from
a tropical space this series of
paintings is about black mothers the
series of paintings takes place in a
supersaturated maybe surrealist world
not that far from the one we live in but
in this world the children of these
black women are disappearing
but his work is really about is trauma
the things that black women and women of
color in particular in our community
have to struggle through in order to set
their kids out on the path of life
what's encouraging for me is that this
practice of mind has given me the
opportunity to work with young people in
my community I'm quite certain the
answers are not in me but if I'm hopeful
at all it's that they may be in them
next Haven is a project that started
about five years ago and next Haven is a
40,000 square foot Arts Incubator in the
heart of the Dixville neighborhood and
New Haven Connecticut this is a
predominantly black and brown
neighborhood it is a neighborhood that
has the history of jazz at every corner
our neighborhood in many ways has been
disinvested in schools which are
struggling to really prepare our
population for the futures ahead of them
I know that creativity is an essential
asset it takes creativity to be able to
imagine a future that is so different
than the one that is before you and so
every artists in our program has a high
school studio assistant as a high school
student that comes from the city of New
Haven who works with them and learns
their craft learns their their practice
and so we've seen the ways in which
pointing folks at the power of
creativity can change them beauty is is
complicated because of how we define it
I think that beauty and truth are
intertwined somehow there is something
beautiful and truth-telling that is that
as an act truth-telling and the myriad
ways it manifests there's beauty in that
[Music]